230 مهاجرا وصلوا الى ميناء تونس عسكري
هنا في جنوب فرنسا علمتني سفينه الانقاذ
التابعه لمنظمه اس او اس ميديتيراني اوشن
فايكنج بقوارب مطاطيه غمر سوريون
وسودانيون ومصريون وافارق بحياتهم في
البحر انطلاقا من ليبيا قبل ان تنتشلهم
سفينه الانقاذ 57 قاصرا 40 منهم غير
مصحوبين بذويهم وخمسه اطفال دون سن الخمس
سنوات استقبلتهم فرنسا وحشدت طاقما كبيرا
من الاطباء والمعالجين النفسيين لتقديم
المساعده لهم فبينهم اشخاص تعرضوا للتعذيب
على يد عصابات في ليبيا بس همم
هناك اشخاص عاش 18 يوما في البحر بعدما
غادروا بلدانهم انهم اشخاص في وضع كارثيه
بينهم اشخاص غير مصحوبين بدويهم وهم بحاجه
ماسه للمساعده
طوق النجاه الذي رمته فرنسا لهؤلاء طرفقا
مع اصوات معترضه فزعيمه اقصى اليمين مارين
لوبين طالبت باعاده المهاجرين من حيث اتوا
وكذلك فعل زعيم حزب الاسترداد اليمين
المتطرف اليكزمور الذي حضر شخصيا الى
المرفق وسط اجواء مشحونه وطوق امنيا فرض
على المنطقه التي رست فيها السفينه من
البر والبحر
فرنسا
من قبل مكتب الهجره واللجوء الفرنسي حيث
ستبقي فرنسا على ثلثهم اما البقيه
سيغادرون ليتم نقلهم الى 11 بلدا اوروبيا
اعلنوا الاستعداد الاستقبالهم في هذه
الدهوك من مدينه تونس وجنوب فرنسا العربيه